why
so as we pick up with the second half of
Infinity Gauntlet issue number five
we're actually going to see things move
at a crew at a pretty quick pace in
addition we're going to see the
circumstances begin to flip on Thanos
and again this is all tied to Thanos as
arrogance because what we see taking
place here is that The Watcher is
informing us that Thanos has usurped the
role of eternity and so within the
earth-616 universe
Thanos reign supreme Thanos has absolute
power and Thanos comments on this Thanos
responds tutor Axia when when she asked
him about his body and he says it's no
longer needed that he's rid himself of
something as bases flesh and that he's
rid himself of all vulnerable 'ti and
the watcher comments The Watcher says
that because Thanos has absolute power
within this universe that Thanos can
virtually change anything he wants to
that the earth-616 universe is subject
to as every whim and that this may very
well lead to the destruction of the
universe or even if it doesn't it may
lead to the universe being uh I guess
irrevocably changed but what we see
taking place here is that again
Thanos as arrogance has gotten the best
of him that in Thanos failing to more or
less keep things in check that he has to
come to the fact that there are
individuals out there despite the fact
that they're only mortal that do have
the ability to defeat him and the reason
for this is because while Thanos has
swept up in the idea of having absolute
power he fails to realize that nebula
has her own thoughts and her own
emotions that nebula despite the fact
that she's somewhat of a husk has this
understanding that Thanos wielding
absolute power with the Infinity
Gauntlet could simply just be seized
from him if she chose to do so
and that's what she does what we see is
that almost immediately after Thanos who
serves the role of eternity and while
everybody else is distracted nebula
takes the chance to take the Infinity
Gauntlet from Thanos and when she does
vanos reverts back to his normal form he
loses this absolute power
Tarak SIA initially tries to intervene
here she tries to stop nebula but she's
not able to and so what we see is that
nebula using the Infinity Gauntlet
restores herself back to her previous
form back to the point in which she is a
normal healthy being and so she sort of
taunts Thanos here
she tells Thanos that the the mantle of
absolute power rests on new shoulders
that she is in fact the one that wields
absolute power and what she tells Thanos
is that of all the things that she could
do with the Infinity Gauntlet the one
thing she wants to do most at this
moment is to get revenge on Thanos and
so what she does is she banishes Thanos
and Terr axia into deep space from here
we transitioned back to Adam warlock the
Silver Surfer and Doctor Strange and the
residence of dr. strange and Adam
warlock immediately realizes that the
Infinity Gauntlet has changed hands that
Thanos is no longer in possession of it
and so what he says here is that things
have gone from bad to worse now why this
has happened is something that we own we
won't fully understand for the next a
little bit but Adam warlock simply gives
us a brief explanation by saying that
nebula as a result of her experience
walking the line between life and death
in addition to the past experiences she
has had has left her in a state of total
derangement and pain and anguish and so
as a result she could very well just
destroy the universe without really
intending to and so what we see is Adam
warlock telling dr. strange that they
need his uh his mystic powers from here
we transitioned back to to Thanos and
tur axia and what we see Fano is doing
here is beachy
I guess lamenting in a way is more or
less remorse in over the fact that Tarak
SIA has died and the reason why is
because while Thanos had created two
racks using the power of the Infinity
Gauntlet he had not created her in a way
to where she could survive deep space
and so she's not able to survive she has
in fact died as a result of her
inability to presumably breathe outside
of the protection of the shrine he had
created for mistress death and so Thanos
feels left alone he feels like he's the
only one left and for the most part he's
beginning to think about this he's
beginning to draw on
the experience of losing an individual
that he held most dearly when a portal
opens beneath him and the gravity on the
other side of the portal pulls him
through once Thanos gets through the
portal what we see is that he's joined
joining Adam warlock the Silver Surfer
and Doctor Strange
again within the residence of Doctor
Strange and the immediate reaction of
the Silver Surfer is to attack Thanos
and again the reason why here is because
the Silver Surfer despite the fact that
he had led Galactus to various planets
had always led Galactus to uninhabited
planets after the silver surfers
encounter with the Fantastic Four and so
he view stano's as a person beyond any
sort of a remorse a person beyond any
ability to I guess maybe make up for
August to atone for his actions and so
he feels as though the only thing that
can be done here is to destroy Thanos
but how it also go as far as to say that
there's a little bit of revenge here -
in the sense that Thanos had killed
helpless beings now initially Doctor
Strange tries to intervene but Adam
warlock tells him to stay back because
the power between the Silver Surfer and
Thanos is more than Adam warlock or
Doctor Strange can deal with and so Adam
warlock tells Doctor Strange to us
summon help Doctor Strange says he's
ahead of Adam warlock here and what we
see is that Doctor Strange opens a
portal and when he does he retrieves the
only five superheroes that had survived
the encounter with Thanos these
superheroes being Erik Masterson his
Thor The Incredible Hulk Fire Lord
Doctor Doom and Drax the destroyer and
when they arrive they're able to pull
that os-- and the Silver Surfer of heart
Adam warlock begins to comment and say
that the whole reason why Thanos is here
is to help them save the universe from
destruction and what Thanos does is he
gives us an explanation as to why it is
the Infinity Gauntlet is in such
dangerous hands in the possession of
nebula what Thanos tells us here is that
it's not enough to simply just wield the
Infinity Gauntlet that the Infinity
Gauntlet has an intense Toller takes an
intense toll on the mind of the person
who wields it and that Thanos by virtue
of his intellect and his past
experiences in addition to the fact that
he is a hybrid of I guess deviant and
eternal genes of sorts is it was able to
manipulate the infinity gone to her he
could control it more or less but that
nebula doesn't have this nebula does not
have the intellect to withstand the
overwhelming sensations that the
Infinity Gauntlet brings to her she
doesn't have the the mental fortitude to
withstand the sudden rush of the
recognition of all life in the universe
the sudden rush of the knowledge of
knowing that everything is within her
control and so because of this her mind
as fragile as it is may very well crack
and when it does she may subconsciously
destroy the universe and everybody in it
and so what we see is that we transition
back to Adam warlock and we see Adam
warlock more or less asking everybody if
they agree to the plan that he's created
now at the moment we don't know what
this plan is and we actually won't find
out what it is until Infinity Gauntlet
issue number six and when Adam warlock
and Thanos or alone Adam warlock I guess
I Thanos asked Adam warlock what it is
that he wants and Adam warlock says that
they need Thanos help that is not simply
as though Thanos can or cannot choose
that they the plan cannot go through if
Thanos doesn't agree to a system and
Thanos asks why he says what would
happen if he chose not to to intervene
if he chose not to fight on behalf of of
Adam warlock and the other superheroes
and the question is what does he benefit
from or what benefit does he gain if he
chooses to fight on their behalf Adam
warlock replies by saying that he'll
give a knows the truth and Thanos asks
what truth he's talking about and Adam
warlock says it is to the truth within
Thanos and this is a very intriguing
conversation here because what Adam
warlock tells us is that while he was
within the soul Jim and while Thanos
wielded the soul Jim where as long as it
was in his possession that Adam warlock
had a very unique viewpoint of Thanos
his inner soul he was able to in fact
look
and Pharaohs himself and the one thing
that he was able to understand here is
that Thanos subconsciously realized that
he was not worthy of wielding absolute
power and this is the reason why every
attempt the Thanos had made to to gain
absolute power had always failed Adam
warlock goes on to say that when Thanos
first first appeared in Marvel Comics
and he was attempting to wield the
Cosmic Cube that subconsciously he
allowed Captain Marvel to destroy the
Cosmic Cube that when he had gained the
infinity gems for the first time and
combine them into one massive gem that
again he subconsciously allowed himself
to be defeated and that allowing himself
to become one with eternity and despite
the fact that he could have easily
stopped it allowing nebula to gain the
Infinity Gauntlet was yet again another
example of him subconsciously
recognizing that he's the means to his
own defeat that he recognizes
subconsciously that he's not able to
wield absolute power or that he's not
worthy of it and so there's always this
part of his mind that creates a set of
circumstances where by his defeat will
be inevitable
Thanos begins to look into himself and
realize that this is true and so he
agrees to to add a Morlocks plan from
here we transition back to nebula and
what we see is that nebula is speaking
with eros despite the fact that he can
still he still is unable to talk and
what nebula says is that she's beginning
to understand Fanus is hungry for power
the hunger for the infinite might of the
Infinity Gauntlet and the reason why is
because her mind may not necessarily be
a shattered as we were led to believe
now we don't really know if she's been
able to overcome the sudden influx of
all facets of reality but what she tells
eros is that she recognizes that all of
reality is hers to sculpt that she can
do anything she wants to with it and
that she will never again be subjected
to a position where she will be made to
I guess engage in activities that she
would normally be against now this isn't
designed to indicate anything sexual in
the sense that she was made to you know
engage in any kind of sexual activity
it's more of the
that she would be subject to somebody
else's whim she would be made to kill
other people or she would be made to
conquer other races instead she could do
whatever it is that she wants and so
what she says is that it's a very
satisfying thing to us or to her that is
a very satisfying feeling to know that
there's nothing that can overcome her
and what she does is she kind of gives a
demonstration of the power she possesses
by saying as she's aware that there is
going to be a coming battle that in
exactly five seconds the earthbound
superheroes will be arriving and so what
we see is that a portal opens up almost
immediately after this is said and that
the earthbound superhero is a fire Lord
on a Thor dr. doom The Incredible Hulk
and racks a destroyer arrive and attempt
to defeat nebula but again she used the
power of the Infinity Gauntlet to
demonstrate that there's nothing they
can do to stop her and what she does
she encases them and some sort of weird
kind of rocky I guess force for some
kind of rocky form to where all of them
are locked in place and there's nowhere
they can go and so what she says is that
she realizes that this is not simply
just the arbitrary actions of a handful
of superheroes doing what they can to
defeat her that this has all been
orchestrated and that most likely this
has been orchestrated by Thanos and so
what we see is that Adam warlock the
Silver Surfer Thanos and Doctor Strange
up here and that they're going to do
what they can to defeat nebula and again
we'll see this plan come to fruition and
issue number six with that being said
we're going to go ahead and bring this
video to an end I hope you guys enjoyed
it if you did let me know and I will
catch you guys at it
you